el Kevin insiste en que no está
preparando una segunda ola de
reclutamiento pero el hecho es que el
gobierno ruso acaba de aprobar una ley
que reforma el sistema de llamar a filas
y va a hacer que sea prácticamente
imposible escapar de las oficinas de
reclutamiento hasta ahora se enviaba la
citación por correo postal pero ahora va
a ser de manera electrónica y se
considerará recibida desde el mismo
momento en el que se emita a partir de
ese momento las fronteras estarán
cerradas para las personas que han
recibido esa citación electrónica pero
también va a ser muy difícil el llamado
exilio interior es decir quedarse en
Rusia sin pasarse por la oficina de
alistamiento desde el mismo momento en
el que se reciba la citación los
seleccionados tendrán 20 días para
presentarse y si no lo hacen no podrán a
partir de ese momento conducir ni
tampoco pagar impuestos o gestionar
ayudas esta